hi Samuel Leeds here I hope you havin a
fantastic day we've just had a beautiful
lunch and I've been walking around the
city of Litchfield which is where I live
and today I've been hanging out with a
guy called Lewis Thomas he's an awesome
guy
HiFi the Lewis come on in the video bro
hey what's up you guys this my man Lewis
now I wanted to bring him in because
he's got a really really popular YouTube
channel himself on crypto currencies
some of his videos have had like over a
million views so this guy is really
really good to watch what's your topic
crypto cryptocurrencies Bitcoin and
everything blockchain based have you
made a lot of money yourself I have done
quite well I was four here to get in I'm
not actually I'm still relatively new
which is a crazy thing I got in towards
very beginning of 2017
pretty good time I've been able to enjoy
some pretty excellent returns so far so
he's a successful youtuber he's also a
successful crypto currency trader
I must they call a Hodler hold all right
modeler so do check in my exams Lewis
Thomas but just a couple of questions to
ask you really just generally about
success mindset of an investor yeah what
would you say your number one tip is you
just being successful in general
regardless of your industry well that's
property business crypto whatever from
my experience so far the number one
would have to be consistency you know
whether you're feeling like it or not
whether you're feeling inspired or not
sometimes the situation demands that you
just grind it out and just queueing
that's been the number one thing for my
youtube for an out videos you know as
often as I can
maybe three to five times per week yeah
and it's the same with the best thing
you have to keep researching keep on top
of whatever it is you're following you
invested in yeah a hundred percent
consistency has been being number one
thing for me so far that's quite all so
you really share my beliefs of formulas
not feelings and you're very much into
investing trading making decisions based
off your logic your mind not your
logical mind
talk a little bit other yeah absolutely
especially within best thing it's very
easy for your feelings to get your
carried away get hold of you in
cryptocurrency we have all these kind of
nerdy little terms and so there are
these two things called FOMO which is
fear of missing out and third which is
fear uncertainty and doubt and the very
very best investors in that space are
the people who are able to effectively
manage both their FOMO
effort so you don't chase the coin this
is pumping and yeah and you don't sell
this the second day you get and it's the
same reverse you know we chase after a
property deal because it looks pretty
and then it falls through we like oh my
goodness because because we have fallen
in love with it but you know in order to
be successful I think in pretty much any
business it really has to boil down to
you using your logic about your brain
not using your feelings but using your
guts using your logic using your
formulas super super important you also
came down to the crash course yes you
guys it's amazing please if you haven't
been already do so I came down to the
London crash course I believe with the
amuel and it was just awesome news two
days of pure value I knew pretty much
nothing about property going into it
this is my wait just learn something
completely new to because I wanted to
diversify a bit away from
cryptocurrencies I'm so happy I went
with Samuel great cost
I definitely yeah great stuff and then
the last point as well while we're doing
this you can go live we were just
chatting about the importance of hanging
around good like-minded similar people
and I just think it's so important so
it's a bank on Monday today I hope you
enjoying the barbecues and the Sun I can
see my wife and baby over on the grass
just sleeping but but but you know don't
forget to really really important
surround yourself with people that
believe in you surround yourself with
people that are positive
surround yourself people that are
successful and I said to Lewis I said
even if you got someone in your family
you can't just cut family off because
they're your family but what you can do
is you can limit how much time you spend
with them or how much they can talk bad
stuff over your life she report anything
down that yeah and another thing you can
do as well if any of you guys sat at
home thinking well I don't really have
any kind of network any people in my
life I can learn from in that sense
fortunately we have the internet we have
YouTube right now many of the people
that I feel I've learned the most from
in life generally these days are on
YouTube I feel like any guys I've never
actually met personally my mentors and
I've learned just invaluable information
from them and so you'd soups a free
resource please take advantage yeah and
Lewis was saying to me today we're
saying you know what cuz I you just saw
the castle that I bought and we've been
talking today about my portfolio and in
property and who said one enough do you
spend time running all these free events
you understand the YouTube because it's
fun and you get a be said what you know
to go to hotels and run these events
consuming why do you do that and what
did I say because he loves it because he
wants to provide value and he wants to
have a meaningful impact on people's
lives yeah and and the impact that you
have from live events so I would say
yeah absolutely be a YouTube YouTube a
YouTube maniac absolutely but get down
meet people in real life come on down to
my property investors crash course link
up with people build relationships you
ended up as going to California yeah
yeah to meet up with a multi-millionaire
in California who's absolutely crushing
it on the internet and marketing and how
did that come about from a comment on a
YouTube video a comment on a YouTube
video sometimes I really all it comes
down so you just have to if you want to
connect with people you have to put the
effort in yes you never know it might
just take one little thing that will
have a tremendous impact on your life so
literally a comment on a YouTube video
taking it that little bit of action
here's a pin it was all paid for and
stuff all paid for Beverly Hills luxury
five-star can't complete the whole
hangout of multi millionaires so what I
want to urge you to do right now take
action today
comment on this video below the number
one thing that you're going to actually
do and implement from this video in your
life to be more successful and will
afford to read in the comments below
catch new guys god bless you folks see
you next time